[MUSIC PLAYING]
- OK, welcome back
to our conference
on Universities and Slavery.
After this very powerful
and moving beginning
this morning, I'm delighted to
announce the first panel, which
is going to be on the
Universities and Slavery
in the United States.
And I'm delighted
and honored to be
able to introduce my
colleague, my co-conspirator
in this project, and also
friend, Professor Evelyn
Higginbotham.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, welcome.
This is really a
wonderful morning.
Few recent conversations
in academia
have elicited more publicity
than the conversation
on the historical relationship
between universities
and slavery.
Inspired by Brown University's
President, Ruth Simmons
in 2003, the investigation into
the connections between slavery
and Brown prompted researchers
at many universities
to conduct similar studies.
And so now we are well
over a decade later,
and this research has
revealed many universities,
southern and northern,
private and public,
to have histories
tied to slavery.
And we now know that slaves
worked on university campuses.
And they were owned
by universities.
Universities engaged in
the buying and selling
of enslaved workers,
and they drew
upon the profits of
their labor, and they
drew upon the profits generated
by the Atlantic slave trade.
And the research on
universities and slavery
has also attracted widespread
controversy as we know,
from articles written in the New
York Times and in other places.
And so this panel on slavery
and universities nationally,
will discuss those issues.
We will hear from James
Campbell, formerly
at Brown University, and
now the Edgar E Robinson
Professor in the United
States history at Stanford.
Our second panelist is Adam
Rothman, Professor of History
at Georgetown University.
And finally, Craig Wilder,
the Barton L Weller Professor
of History at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
Now you can read their
full bios in your program.
After their presentations,
and after our conversation,
we will entertain questions
from you, from the audience,
and index cards have been given
to every registered attendee
in Agassiz and in Knafel.
And audience members should
write their questions
on index cards--
you can do that as
you're listening--
and there will be
staff members who
will walk quietly up
and down the aisles
to pick up your cards.
And those cards have
different colors,
so we want to make sure that we
get people from both locations,
and that we will be able to
answer some of those questions.
And in addition, we will be
taking questions from Twitter.
And we are using the
hashtag unislavery--
can you see that?
Hashtag unislavery, so
that people watching online
can submit questions.
So let's start.
Professor Campbell, you
played a pioneering role
in the study of slavery
and universities
with your work with
the leadership of Ruth
Simmons at Brown University.
I'd love to hear
your reflections
on the particular
set of contingencies
that came together at Brown.
And if you can
also share with us
your thoughts about the
politics of confronting
this difficult
matter at that time.
- Well a couple of things.
First of all, thank
you all for being here,
and thanks for having me.
The historically
contingent thing at Brown
has to do with the
reparations debate.
And I'm going to go around a bit
of a mountain to get to this.
But in 2001, 2002,
before Ruth Simmons
had become the President
of Brown University,
but shortly after
her appointment
had been announced as the first
African-American president
of an Ivy League
university, there
was an advertisement that
was taken out-- a paid
advertisement in the
Brown Daily Herald
and a variety of other college
newspapers around the country
by a conservative columnist
named David Horowitz mocking
the reparations movement.
It was called Ten Reasons
Why Reparations For Slavery
is a Bad Idea and Racist Too.
And with all respect,
I think it was
meant to be a kind of
political provocation.
It sort of was a series
of 10 escalating reasons,
each of which was more
provocative, I guess,
than the previous, that
African-Americans should
be grateful that their ancestors
were enslaved because they was
so much better off by virtue
of being here than being
in Africa, that reparations
had already been
paid in the form of welfare.
That African-Americans
were not sufficiently
grateful to the white
Christians who freed them.
And I think the 10th one was
that any disparities that
existed between black and white
people in the United States
today were not a function of
an institution that had ended
hundreds of years
ago-- his words--
but merely reflected black
people's own failures
of individual character.
Well, if it was meant to
provoke a response, it did.
It did on a number of campuses.
At Brown he hit the jackpot,
where a group of students
incensed by it, demanded
that the editorial be
rescinded by the editors.
When they refused,
this group of students
announced that they would
prevent the Brown Daily Herald
from circulating until such
time as the editors met
their demands.
Well, I don't know if you can
steal something that's free,
but the next day when the Brown
Daily Herald was distributed,
there were protesters at each
of the distribution points
and they made off with
the day's press run.
And the day after
that, Brown was
on the front page of the New
York Times, the Washington
Post, the Wall Street Journal,
the Christian Science Monitor.
It made the London
Times, MSNBC, BBC
News as an example
of an institution
where the students were
so politically correct
that when confronted with ideas
that made them uncomfortable,
their only response was
to smash the presses.
It was not a happy day
for the University.
Given that background,
and it sort of
was a convulsion on
the campus that we
dealt with for some
number of weeks,
one might have thought
that a president coming
to Brown at that moment,
very conspicuous given
the circumstances, would
have given this issue a very
wide berth, but Ruth, in
her courage and her vision,
did precisely the opposite.
Her very first speech
at Brown at Convocation,
she reminded students that
universities were conflicted
places where we had to have
the courage to debate even
the most painful issues.
And shortly thereafter,
she announced a commission
to actually investigate not only
Brown's historical relationship
to slavery in the
Transatlantic slave trade,
and to publish
the facts of that,
but also to organize
public programs that
would help our students and
the nation reflect thoughtfully
in academically rigorous ways
on the complex legal, political,
ethical, moral questions raised
by the slavery reparations
issue.
This was an act of
transcendent courage.
And when she did it,
she was all alone.
And I must say, with respect to
all of the other institutions
that are engaged
with this work now,
there wasn't a single peep
from another university
even suggesting that this was
an act worthy of a university.
Sort of people just
kind of waited to see.
And so I think the first
answer to your question
is that we're here because
of the courage of a rather
singular woman.
But there's other
things as well.
I was struck this
morning, just to broaden
the lens a little
bit, Dean Cohen,
in her introduction talked
about how we are here
engaging urgent questions.
And it's kind of interesting
to reflect as a historian
why a question
becomes urgent when
the matters about which you're
talking are centuries old.
And there's a history here.
And it's kind of been
interesting to me
that our movement,
if I might call it
that, which is predicated on the
importance and value of history
has been so unselfconscious
about thinking
about its own
historical predicates.
And so I'd like to just,
in a couple of minutes,
suggest a few of them.
Clearly the work we are
doing at universities
is part of a global movement.
The period since the
Second World War,
and certainly the last couple
of decades in particular,
have seen a growing
international consensus
on the need for societies
to confront legacies
of gross historical injustice.
And of the development
of a variety
of modalities for doing so.
Truth commissions
being one, war crimes
tribunals, memorials,
monuments, reparations programs
of various kinds.
So that global context I think
is really important here.
I think that global context
also both reflects and feeds off
of other broad changes
in political culture.
One is, and I don't have time
to elaborate this much, but is
what one might call the
therapeutic culture,
particularly the emergence
of the trauma paradigm.
So axiomatic is
it to us, the kind
of logic of PTSD, the idea
that events in our past that
are painful, if
left unaddressed can
continue to remain and hinder
and create dysfunction.
That it's hard for us
to remember that that's
a pretty novel concept.
PTSD is only recognized in
the American Psychiatric
Association's DSM
I think in 1983.
But it is now something that
we all just take axiomatically,
that if something traumatic
happens, you need to deal with.
And what's been fascinating
in those years since 1983,
and I think in interesting
ways rather uninterrogated,
is the ways in which
what began as a diagnosis
for an individual
psyche has increasingly
become, through the
use of metaphor,
a way in which we talk
about collectives,
and we talk about
entire human society.
So we now routinely
talk about societies
having traumatic histories,
and about the need
to confront these
painful pasts in order
for the society to move forward.
I don't offer this
comment as a skeptic.
I think we need to think
carefully about it,
but simply because
again, I think
is one of the contexts in which
these kind of investigations
become plausible.
Another one very
briefly is, I think,
what philosopher
Charles Taylor calls
the politics of recognition.
The emergence and, at
least in Western societies,
a shift in the way in
which rights claims, which
historically might
have been enunciated
in terms of individual's access
to certain basic civil rights
are increasingly
articulated in group terms,
and in the right of people to
have the collective identities
that they cherished acknowledged
in the public sphere,
including histories of trauma
or histories of violation.
And I think that too, is
one of the contexts that
is behind the kind
of transformations
that we're seeing.
And finally, and
this was obviously
germane to the thing at Brown,
is the reparations movement
itself.
As Ta-Nehisi Coates mentioned
today, there's a long history,
and it's one we're tied to at
Harvard from the Belinda Royall
petition, and
reparations demands
have been made and articulated
and movements have emerged off
and on for more than 200 years.
But in the 1990s, inspired by
a series of settled lawsuits
involving Holocaust
reparations, a new front
was opened there in
which the idea was
to bring claims
against corporations
that had profited from slavery.
And that was a new approach.
And it was one that immediately
brought universities
to the center.
And so I think, as you
might remember Yale,
Harvard, Brown, all of them
were threatened with litigation.
Some lawsuits were filed.
In the end, those lawsuits
were consolidated and heard
in federal court in
2004 and thrown out.
But, the fact is, that again,
when the events at Brown
happened, there were just a
host of broad developments
that had set the stage
for a kind of response
that seemed logical,
inevitable, even
though a generation
or two before nobody
would have thought of it.
So I hope that helps.
- Thank you, yes.
Professor Rothman, Georgetown
has already been mentioned
and it offers perhaps
the most dramatic case,
in recent years of a
university's coming to terms
with its past because of
the historical research
that was done.
However, you have
identified, and indeed
you even emphasize the unique
role of memory in regard
to Georgetown's response.
So talk to us about memory,
how you think about that
in relation to history.
- Thanks very much.
I should just begin by
saying it's a real honor
to be here, to be able to
discuss this issue that
is so important and so central
to the identities and politics
of our own institutions.
I'm a historian of slavery
at an institution that
owes its existence to
the history of slavery.
And I just think about
that all the time.
I was a member of the
working group at Georgetown.
The title of the working group
was the Work Group on Slavery,
Memory, and Reconciliation.
And I want to really focus
on that idea of the memory
of slavery at Georgetown.
But to talk about memory, we
have to talk a little bit first
about the actual history.
I'm sure many of you by now are
very familiar with the history
of Georgetown and slavery.
That history is really a
microcosm of the entire history
of slavery in North America.
Georgetown was founded in
1789 by Catholic and Jesuit
leadership in the Chesapeake,
especially in Maryland.
That Catholic and
Jesuit leadership,
that elite derived its wealth
and power from slave owning.
The Maryland province
of the Society
of Jesus in the
18th century became
one of the largest slave owners
in the colony of Maryland.
And the idea, when
Georgetown was founded,
was that the the Jesuit farms
and plantations out in Maryland
would essentially
subsidize the educational,
and religious mission
of the Catholic church.
So there's a very
intimate relationship
between slavery and Georgetown.
Georgetown is part-- was part
of a religious economy rooted
in slavery.
Enslaved people
worked at Georgetown.
Georgetown hired slaves
from neighboring owners
and from students.
At one point in the 1810s, about
10% of all the people on campus
were slaves.
But after the War of 1812, as
the economy of slavery changes
in the Chesapeake,
the Jesuits begin
to debate what to
do with their slaves
because the plantations
were no longer profitable,
they weren't making money.
The Jesuits have
a 20-year debate
about what to do with
them, whether to free them,
whether to sell them, whether
to send them to Liberia.
These were all things
that were discussed.
But ultimately, by the
1830s, the Jesuit leadership
decided to sell virtually
their entire inventory
of human property.
One of the reasons why
they decided to sell
was because Georgetown
was in debt--
accumulated debt
through building
in the 1820s and 1830s.
So the sale of the
slaves in the 1830s
actually kills two
birds with one stone.
They sort of liquidate
their human assets
and at the same
time, raise capital
to resuscitate the
finances of the university.
So when Mr. Coates
talks about the debt
that this country
has to slavery,
that debt, with respect
to Georgetown University
is very real.
You can actually
put a number on it.
The Jesuit leadership
sold 272 people,
give or take, for
about $115,000 in 1838.
And some of that money
flowed back to the University
to pay off the debts.
That's the history
in a nutshell.
But here's the thing, that
history was never a secret.
Jesuit historians had
been writing about it
since the early 20th century.
In the 1980s and 1990s, the
American Studies program
at Georgetown actually
integrated this history
into its curriculum.
Some people around
the University
knew it, scholars wrote about
it, the bicentennial history
of the University written in
1989, discusses this history.
It was never a secret.
But it is also not widely known.
So when President
DeGioia at Georgetown
initiated the working
group on slavery, memory,
and reconciliation
at Georgetown,
a lot of people around the
University and the broader
public were just
shocked at this history
because they had no idea
that this had ever happened.
And so when we
talk about memory,
I think we have to talk about--
and this is to all the
scholars and the room--
we have to talk about the
failure of scholarship
to reach the broader public.
We have not been successful
telling the stories
that we know are true.
So I think part of the work
that we've been engaging in
in Georgetown is to try to
dig deeper into this history
and find out new things.
But even more important perhaps,
to tell the story in ways
that make it known.
So memory.
How have we done that?
Well, partly just the
working group itself,
excavating the history,
telling the story.
We created a website called
the Georgetown Slavery
Archive, to put documents on the
web so people could see this,
see the original
materials for themselves.
It's one thing to be told
that the Jesuits sold
nearly 300 people.
And it's another thing to see
the contract where their names
are listed from Isaac on down.
So I think that is a way
of recovering that memory.
The discussions that we've had
about the naming and renaming
of buildings, about
memorialization,
all are about
resuscitating that memory.
But memory is not
just about archives.
It's about the uses of history.
It's about the fights
we have over history.
And over the course of last
year, we had a couple of things
happen that really elevated
this history into a kind
of new level of consciousness.
One was a series of protests
by students at Georgetown
last fall, insisting
among other things,
that the names of
buildings that were
named after the architects
of the sale be changed.
They did not want to live
with those names anymore.
So that was an invocation
of a new form of memory.
But we tried to find new
names for those buildings that
would not erase this
history but remind us
of this history in new ways.
So I think that's
part of our challenge.
The second thing
that happened, and I
think one of the things that
really makes the Georgetown
story so powerful, not
unique but powerful,
is the revelation that so
many living descendants
of the people who
were sold in 1838
are walking among us today.
They live in Louisiana
in a little town
where their ancestors
were sold in 1838.
They live in New Orleans, in
Minnesota, and California.
Some of them live in Maryland.
Some of them are at
Georgetown today.
We have to thank Rachel Swarns,
New York Times reporter,
and Richard Cellini of the
Georgetown memory project
for really elevating that story
and making it an important part
of our own history.
But I think that we
need to tell the story.
We need to tell it accurately.
We need to tell it thoroughly.
And we need to find
new ways to tell it.
That is part of the
process of reconciliation,
which is the third
basket of ideas
that the working
group was operating
with-- reconciliation.
Part of reconciliation
is telling the story,
not just having
historians write about it,
but having playwright's
craft plays,
and philosophers wrestle
with the question
of moral obligations
across time,
and people studying economics
to look at the finances of it.
Reconciliation involves
telling the story in new ways,
incorporating new people's
perspectives and opinions
and archives to just develop a
much richer and more compelling
story that speaks to us today.
That's what we try to
do on the working group.
The working group is
actually concluded,
but the work continues.
At Georgetown, in all
sorts of partnerships
with other institutions and
organizations and people,
this work of slavery memory
and reconciliation is not over.
And our hope at Georgetown,
is that it's actually
just beginning.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Now Professor Wilder, you've
written a wonderful new book.
And one of the concerns
that you have is obviously
related to what
we've just heard,
and that's about
the controversies in
regard to naming and renaming.
So please talk about
the politics of this
and why naming has become such
a crucial part of activism.
- Thank you.
And thank you all for having me.
It's been extraordinary
so far, and I
hope I don't make it less so.
[LAUGHTER]
- That's my goal that's
what I'm shooting for.
I want to go back in time to,
n part because I'm at Harvard,
so I want to talk a
bit about WB Dubois
because you can't
have a conference here
without doing that, so
let's make sure it's done.
Dubois' In Souls
of Black Folk has
an essay of Alexander
Crummell that I've read
dozens and dozens of times.
I've taught it.
It's become sort of a
part of the way I think
about the world, about
African-American history,
about the history of education.
And it's an extraordinary essay.
It begins in fact,
with this paragraph.
"This is the history
of a human heart.
The tale of a black boy, who
many long years ago began
to struggle with life that
he might know the world
and know himself.
Three temptations he met
on those dark dunes that
lay gray and dismal before
the wonder eyes of the child.
The temptation of hate that
stood out against the red dawn,
the temptation of despair
that darkened the noon day,
the temptation of doubt
that ever steals along
with twilight.
Above all you must hear
of the vales he crossed,
the valley of humiliation
and the valley
of the shadow of death."
It is hardly the
introduction that you
would expect to read to
a biography of someone's
educational journey,
but that's exactly
in fact, what Dubois offers.
Dubois follows
Alexander Crummell
from his childhood in New York
in the old African school.
He follows him and
two other teenagers
from New York City, who
journey alone up to Canaan,
New Hampshire to a school
that's willing to accept
black students.
The school is surrounded by
a mob of 300 people on August
10th, 1835.
The mob dresses the
building in ropes and chains
and spends the next
two days ripping it off
of its foundations,
dragging it through town,
depositing it at the rear
end of a Baptist church.
And then celebrates
their victory
by turning on the
children with guns,
and using a cannon to
chase them out of town
under the cover of night.
He then follows Crummell
back to New York City.
And yet again, on another
educational journey,
this time up to
Petersboro, where
the abolitionist
Garrett Smith had
opened a school for black kids.
He followed him
again to Oneida where
the radical white
minister, Boriah Green,
had had a school
where he had promised
to take in a black student.
He follows Crummell
back to New York.
He follows him to
Yale, where apparently,
like GWC Pennington, a fugitive
slave from Maryland, Crummell
was allowed to take
a course, but not
allowed to actually speak,
matriculate, get a degree,
or participate in any other
formal way in the institution.
He just follows him.
The temptation, hate,
despair, and doubt framed
Dubois short
biography of Crummell.
And Dubois will write, 'out
of the temptation of hate,
and burned by the fire of
despair, triumph over doubt,
and steeled by the sacrifice
against humiliation,"
Crummell becomes, in
fact, the black leader
who Dubois meet in the
late 19th century in Ohio.
The black man, the
black leader who
Dubois feels he can actually
bow before and really
come to understand.
And one of the things I've
always found extraordinary
about that document is that
it repeats throughout much
of Dubois' work, but it
repeats throughout much
of African-American history.
This story, this narrative
arc of struggle and triumph,
of trials and tribulations
and then success.
In Dubois' 1928
novel, Dark Princess,
he does much the same thing.
This time he has a black
medical student who he basically
positions him before the
dean of a new medical college
The student's in his
second year in the novel.
And the whole administration
and the trustees
conspire to actually put
him out of medical school
and make sure that
he doesn't graduate.
The novel then has the
young man basically
on a ship heading to Europe
where he falls in love with--
DuBois liked, in fact,
third world exoticism.
So he falls in love with a
beautiful South Asian woman
and the two of them join
the international struggle
against imperialism.
[LAUGHTER]
- And so you have DuBois.
But one of the things that
I've always been struck by,
and I should say that
character in Dark Princess
is actually based on the
very real black students who
came to Harvard Medical School,
including Martin Delaney, who
were actually conspired against
and removed from the school
before they graduated.
And so it actually
involves in fact,
DuBois' understanding of
African-American education
and African-American history.
DuBois regularly reproduced
narratives of black struggle
and black sacrifice,
this sort of heroic theme
in African-American history that
repeats over and over again.
He was fascinated by these
figures, many of us are.
It's hard to read about
Anna Julia Cooper and others
without actually really
embracing this idea.
And I know as a student, I did.
I read Souls Of Black Folks,
and DuBois read himself
into Alexander Crummell.
He came to understand his life
through Crummell's sacrifices.
And I was very much attracted
to that same possibility
as an undergraduate.
But now that I've
lost my hair, and I've
read that multiple
times since, there's
something else that I've found
much more troubling about it.
That that sort of
triumphant story
in African-American
history and the history
of African-American
education also
tends to normalize
black sacrifice,
black struggle on our campuses.
I was reminded last night
of the demands and protests
of law students at Harvard
around the royal seal,
the crest on the
Harvard Law School seal.
We can also remind
ourselves of the fact that
since the Brown report,
since Ruth Simmons'
extraordinary courage and
opening up this conversation
and challenging, not just
Brown, but all of Brown's peer
institutions to
take a close look
at the relationship between
those institutions and slavery.
One of the groups
that has helped
to keep the
conversation alive has
been students on our campuses.
Very often black
students on our campuses,
but not only black
students on our campuses.
Student protests and student
struggles have helped
to actually keep us honest.
They've brought our institutions
into a confrontation
with history that
we're now challenged
to wrestle with ourselves.
And so one of the things I
want to take from WB DuBois
description of the
glory of black struggle
and black sacrifice
is the possibility
that perhaps it's time
for us to stop that.
And perhaps it's time for us
to really take responsibility
for our own histories, our
faculties, our trustees,
our administrators to confront
that past and actually,
rather than depending upon
our students yet again--
we're about to approach
the 200th anniversary
of the graduation of
the first black student
from a United States college.
And that's 200 years
of triumphant stories.
It's time to stop
that narrative arc.
It's time for us
to actually take up
the burden of social
justice on our campuses
rather than transferring
it to our students.
It's time for us to support the
students in the most direct way
that we can, which is
by actually living up
to the values that we
define ourselves by.
And rather than having our
students rescue us and address
our past, perhaps take this
opportunity to really take
a close reading of ourselves,
understand the moment that
we're in, and give
our students--
this next generation,
the kind of--
address one of the central
demands of student movements,
which is the right to exist
on these campuses in dignity,
without the burden of actually
being insulted, demeaned,
or actually placed in positions,
situations, and contexts
that are by definition
insulting and demeaning
because they're by
definition dishonest.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, thank you.
So now, I'm always curious
about these kind of projects,
when we get involved and we get
so intensely involved, there's
always something that is
absolutely surprising that we
discover or striking
that we discover.
I'd like to your stories.
- Sure.
I'll start by telling a few
things that didn't surprise me.
It didn't surprise me
that the day after Brown
press released what
we were intending
to do that there was a
chorus of denunciations
about a black woman
president who'd lost her mind
and was about to cash
out Brown's endowment
and give it out and reparations
checks to her friends.
I knew that there would
be a political backlash
and I wasn't surprised by that.
I wasn't surprised by the
fact that other universities
would eventually join.
One of the very
first conversations
I had with Simmons about
this I said, people
are going to come after you.
And she said, look, as
long as what we are doing
is constant with the
values of the university,
they can't touch us.
But this is what
universities are.
If you don't like
universities, don't come.
But don't tell universities
that they can't investigate
their own histories,
that they don't
have a linkage to their pasts.
To be a part of a university is
to exist in the community that
exists across time,
a procession that
started before we got here and
will continue long after we're
gone.
And so universities
are also places
that are set up to engage
difficult questions.
So I think a lot of what
we tried to do at Brown
was if we just made it clear
that what we were doing
was in keeping with the
values that we profess
as institutions, that
it would soon enough,
the question would not be why
would one university do this,
it would be how could a
university not investigate
this.
I'll tell you one thing that
did surprise me was discovering
that we were late to the party.
That the questions about what
the university's relationship
to slavery in the
Transatlantic slave trade was
was in fact, one that had been
debated on our campus almost
from its beginning, most
notably in the case of the Brown
brothers themselves.
If you've read the
report, you know--
by the standards of
Rhode Island merchants,
the Brown brothers were not
big players in the trade.
But they did send two
slave ships to Africa,
both were disasters, after
which three of the four
never engaged in
the trade again.
And one of them,
Moses Brown became
one of the founders
of the movement
to abolish the
Transatlantic slave trade.
The first prosecution
for illegal slave trading
in the United States
federal courts
is a prosecution of John Brown
brought by his younger brother
Moses.
So you realize that
in fact, that this
was an-- and the
correspondence between them
is in our archives.
And you realize that in fact,
they've been debating this.
You realize that
in fact, there were
a series of subsequent cases
in which members of the Brown
board of trustees were
bringing prosecutions
against other members of
the Brown board of trustees.
You've probably been in
contentious corporation
meetings, but maybe never
quite as contentious as this.
There was one
moment, the students
too talked about this, and
so just one quick anecdote.
I got a phone call one day
from one of the university
archivists who said, we have
all these Brown commencement
addresses delivered by students,
would you like to see them.
Maybe some of them
talk about slavery.
And so he sent them
to me in digital form,
and one of them I recognized
was James Tallmadge
Now if you're
American historian,
he's the author of The
Tallmadge Amendment, which
precipitates the Missouri
crisis in 1819, a congressman.
And James Tallmadge gave the
Brown commencement address,
I think it's 1794,
I could be wrong.
And he says, I
take as my subject
the subject of this
barbarous traffic.
And you've got to imagine half
the people in the audience
are merchants participating
in the slave trade.
And he works through,
just eloquently and quite
satirically in some
cases, a set of arguments
that are advanced in
support of this traffic
and knocks them down.
And he ends by saying, but
the most absurd one of all
is this newfangled
idea that somehow
a person with darker skin is
inferior to a person of lighter
skin.
An idea, he says, which if
taken to its logical conclusion,
would make the most powerful
Washington subject--
a man as virtuous as Washington
subject to a puny albino.
And he says, this idea is a
matter for future generations
to investigate.
And I remember reading that.
It was late at night and
I was sitting by myself
and I just started to cry
because it was that somebody
had left a message in a bottle.
And so that discovery that
we were not, as some allege,
projecting our values on some
past and you couldn't-- we were
in fact, engaging a past in
precisely the terms that they
had given us.
And we were re-entering
a conversation
that'd been going on campus
for a really long time.
And that surprised me and,
in its way, delighted me.
- I'll tell a story that
also ends with me crying.
[LAUGHTER]
- The most surprising
thing for me
has really been just
the emotional power
that is vested in
archival material
in the way that sort of springs
out at unexpected times.
So a lot of what I was
doing on the working group
was just digging into a
collection called the Maryland
Province Archives, which is 130
odd boxes of material produced
by the Jesuits over a
couple of centuries.
And quite a lot of
material in there
has to do with Jesuit
slave holding--
their attitudes towards
slaves, sacramental
registers that contain
records of the baptism
and marriage and
burial of slaves
on the Jesuit
plantations, and even
in some cases at the college.
And it's really
remarkable-- it's just
remarkable historical material.
If you're a
historian of slavery,
it's really an amazing resource.
I'm fully convinced
that the sale in 1838
is the single best
documented mass sale
of people in the history of
the domestic slave trade.
So it's a really
valuable resource
for historical research.
Last April, during
our emancipation week
at Georgetown, we culminated
or our series of--
culminated our University-wide
event sponsored by the working
group with a series
of talks and lectures,
talking about the history
of slavery at Georgetown,
and more generally.
And I gave a presentation at our
special collections in a room
there.
I'm just presenting
the archival material
that we had uncovered and
put on the website including
baptismal records for
slaves and including letters
that Jesuits had written
about slavery, including
records from this sale.
And I gave a pretty
conventional academic talk
to a fairly conventional
academic crowd.
There was a Q&A at the end.
And as the Q&A went on,
there's a gentleman standing
in the back of the room,
it was a crowded room,
people were interested.
But there's gentleman standing
in the back of the room who
didn't quite fit in the mold.
He was African-American.
He was wearing a
kind of track suit.
He had tattoos all over his
body, the arms and neck.
And he raised his hand and
he just started talking.
And he started to say that
the names that he was reading
on the bill of sale were
names that he recognized,
names from his ancestors.
And he was just
breaking down, crying,
talking about how
those priests, who
were supposed to be
shepherds of their flock,
could sell those people,
how they could send them
to the wolves.
And he was having a crisis
of faith right there.
And he asked me, how
could this happen,
and what are we
going to do about it.
And I had no answer for him.
And by the end of it, we
were pretty much all crying.
And it just revealed to me
the tremendous emotional power
of the archives, the
different ways that people
read them and connect to them.
That they're valuable,
not just as places
we go for information to
make historical arguments,
but for some people it's really
personal and very meaningful.
And that just really--
I was starting to realize that.
But that moment really
made me understand
that we have to
do more to connect
people in visceral
and material ways
to the artifacts of history.
Not that the artifacts
speak for themselves,
they don't, but people
read different things
in those artifacts, and they
bring different perspectives
to them.
And it just was a reminder
that history really matters.
And I think sometimes
that's an important reminder
to get because we
often forget it.
- Thank you.
- I'll be brief.
I'll just add something
I think, to the two.
One of the things I've been
struck by in the past decade--
actually now more than a decade,
since Brown did it's report
is that I've always had this
sense, especially recently,
that there's this interesting
connection between Brown
and Georgetown.
And that they sort of sit at
the ends of two different parts
of this movement.
This process I think is
really quite interesting
because I think the arrival
of Ruth Simmons at Brown
created a kind of public stir,
but also a kind of moral moment
in which Brown's relationship
to the history of slavery
became a kind of
inescapable question.
And she handled this
with extraordinary skill.
And we've talked
about this before,
but left this real
template for everyone
who wanted to do this work
and how you guide this.
And how you do the difficult
work of actually looking
at something that's
extraordinarily painful,
very personal at
times, and use it
to do real community building
and institution building
and make a better institution
out of that moment.
And so at Brown
you have that sort
of extraordinary
set of circumstances
that produces this discussion.
And then at Georgetown,
at the other end--
Georgetown is-- of all the
colleges and universities
established before
1800, it's the only one
that maintains its
religious identity.
And it's precisely
that in some ways that
has created this sort
of moral stir, that
has made the moral
dimension of the 1838 sale,
but also the long history
of Jesuit slaveholding
in Maryland, and the way in
which the Jesuits plantations
funded the entire institution.
There's no tuition for the
first 50 years or whatever.
And it's precisely that
religious dimension
that has made this moral problem
of slaveholding on the campus
inescapable.
And one of the interesting
things that's happened,
and I think in some ways both
institutions deserve credit
for helping us to return that
dimension to the conversation.
We're talking about
a historical problem
that has all sorts of
moral consequences to it.
They're very real.
They're very immediate.
They affect the way that we
think about our own positions
and our own histories, our
places on these campuses
in the extent to which we
take ownership of and feel
part of the very institutions
that we have histories with.
And so I think, for
me, one of the--
it's not so much surprising,
but it is something
that I've been really taken by
is that it has really required
a very long discussion,
a lot of protest,
a lot of what I've been
calling grassroots activism.
Sven, in faculty who just
started teaching classes
on Harvard and slavery
and Colombian slavery.
It required an
extraordinary amount of work
to get us to a moment
where we can actually
talk, not about the history
of colleges and slavery,
but actually admit that there's
a moral dimension to it,
that it actually brings
real responsibilities.
And that that moral dimension
does not give us permission
to escape the problem.
It actually gives
us a greater burden
to actually address
that problem.
- Thank you.
I am fascinated when
I think about 2003,
and now we're in 2017.
And I am curious
about the why now.
Why is it that just in
the last couple of years
though really, we've seen
this real ferment of activism.
Why is the topic of slavery in
the universities so compelling
now and not, maybe 10
years ago or 20 years ago?
Let's reflect upon that
a bit in conversation.
- Let me offer a cynical answer.
I mean one of the things when--
so the reparations
coordinating committee,
I remember published an op
ed in the New York Times
identifying Harvard, Yale,
and Brown as probable targets
of lawsuits.
And there were a series of class
action suits against Aetna,
Fleet Bank, you might remember
the CSX Railroad and others.
And I think it was
in that context
that most universities just
wanted the problem to go away.
It was not only awkward
and embarrassing,
but there was a fear that if
you said a word about this
that you were about to get hit
with a subpoena in a lawsuit.
When we started
the work at Brown,
we talked about this, that we
had to be prepared for the fact
that everything we
were talking about,
we were likely to be
subpoenaed to disclose.
And the fact that
those cases, when
they were heard in federal
court in northern Illinois
and dismissed, statute
of limitations grounds,
failure to establish standing,
political questions doctrine,
a bunch of dismissals was
pretty overwhelming legal defeat
took the immediate threat
of litigation away.
And it made it easier.
So that's just one cynical one.
It's like universities can
take this on without the fear
that the next day they're
getting hit by a lawsuit.
So I don't I don't
normally think about it.
I don't think that's an
overwhelming part of it,
but it certainly is part of it.
It's safer now.
And it's also safer now simply
because the more institutions
have done it, the less
controversial it becomes.
- And even after that,
there's no upside to doing it,
for much of that history.
There's no positive reason.
It doesn't bring
anything-- benefits
and all sorts of things.
And it might well actually stand
in the way of something else.
And I would give a different--
would just add
something to that.
I really think also
the audience changed.
In the past 20
years the audience
for the discussion
of slavery has
changed in the United States,
and actually in the West.
If you think about this sort
of European anniversaries
of the end of the slave trade
and both the scale of those
and the audience for them.
I think around the
world, the audience
for the subject of
slavery is shifting.
And the United States has
shifted on our campuses,
it shifted.
What was, perhaps in the 1970s,
when you go through the first
big process of
both co-education,
but also the racial
integration of these campuses,
what might have been an issue
for small groups of black
students to organize around--
at Dartmouth after 1969,
its 200th anniversary,
when it commits to Native
American education,
one of the consequences of
that is the anti-Indian art
that saturated the visual
culture of the campus.
Graphic, obscene
images of native people
that was deeply rooted
in the sort of, really
the 20th century
history of Dartmouth.
It's invented largely
in the 20th century.
That there was a conflict
between native students--
the commitment to students
and that visual culture.
And so the campus has
to go through a process
of reconstructing
itself to accommodate
the change that happened.
And the people pushing that
conversation at Dartmouth,
at the time are
the incoming class
of Native American students.
They're the ones
writing the letters
to the school newspaper.
They're the ones protesting
in the president's office.
They're carrying the
burden of actually rescuing
the college from its history.
And but I think now that
audience has changed.
There's not a lot
of reason for us
to assume that there are lots
of students in the majority
population who want to sit
in front of stained glass
windows of happy
slaves picking cotton
and embrace that as a part of
their educational experience.
And among the alumni,
among our trustees--
and then I also
want to give credit
to the surrounding communities
around our campuses
who've put extraordinary
pressure on us.
Black New Haven has organized
around the Calhoun College
controversy and some of the
other controversies on campus.
And so I actually
think the landscape
has changed for us a bit so
there is a much harder issue
to escape increasingly.
- I would just add that
I think that part of it
has to do with having more of
a critical mass of students
and faculty of color
on campuses who
can push for these sorts
of acts of recognition.
I just think that's
a big part of it.
Obviously, I mean
at Georgetown, it
was a combination of
national and local politics
making this an opportune time
to investigate this history.
It was also a weight of
scholarship, a critical mass
of scholarship like
Craig's book, which
I know our university president
had read before he initiated
the working group.
Scholarship that helps
to inform these sorts
of investigations, the
models of other universities
that make it more plausible
to do this sort of work.
And this is not
a huge bit, but I
think technology has
something to do with it.
We can communicate
with each other.
We can tell these stories using
new digital tools that weren't
available to us 10 years ago.
And I think that's made
a difference as well.
It's made a big
difference in our ability
to publicize the stories--
to publicize the stories
that we're discovering
or perhaps that we already knew.
- One of the things I was
thinking about from all of you,
and it's something you said,
but it does need, I think,
more explicit discussion.
The people who are
outside of the university,
and for people who have
tried to register for this,
we had so many people who wanted
to participate in this audience
and weren't able to,
but many of those people
were not academics.
Many of these people are from
the surrounding communities.
And I'm just wondering, how
does that surrounding community
factor into projects
such as these?
- One of the interesting
things about the geography
of elite higher education
in the United States
is these venerable
institutions tend
to be established in
northeastern or East coast
cities that, in the
aftermath of 20th century
deindustrialization,
tend to have
very high black
populations, often
black populations living in
great poverty, that are sitting
right next to these campuses.
That's certainly the case
at Penn, it's the case--
I guess Princeton
would be an exception,
but it's certainly
the case at Brown,
it's the case in
various ways here.
Columbia, certainly.
And so I think one of the
really interesting questions
is, how you address this.
The most creative response,
of which I'm aware so far,
is the University of
Virginia, which actually
has used the President's
Commission on Slavery
there to actually--
it has representation of
the surrounding community,
and it is worked very carefully.
Kirk [INAUDIBLE] is here so
he can perhaps speak to this.
But worked very thoughtfully
to use this as an occasion
not only for UVA to come to
terms with its own history,
but to repair a relationship
with the black community that
is, in many cases, descended
of the enslaved people who once
worked on the campus
and who have then
continued to labor on the
campus for generations.
So I think that question
about renegotiating, using
these moments as opportunities
to interrogate and renegotiate
these institutions relationships
with the surrounding
communities of
color around them,
I think that's actually a really
interesting part of the work.
- I think we have
at Georgetown there,
we've discovered multiple
audiences and publics who
are interested in the
history of our university
and its connection to slavery.
And I think at the beginning
of the formation of the working
group, we were quite insular.
It was really about the
university community
and different constituents
at the University
relating to each other
around this history.
But I think over
the course of time,
we've really been stretched
beyond the walls of the campus
to multiple publics
and audiences.
My colleague, Professor
Maurice Jackson is here.
Mr. Jackson has been involved in
a project for a long time that
produced a book called
Black Georgetown Remembered.
Georgetown used to be a heavily
African-American neighborhood
as late as the mid 20th century.
And then it basically
got gentrified
and the black
community of Georgetown
was moved out or forced out.
But they come back for events
around Black Georgetown
Remembered and
still have a stake
in the neighborhood and
institutions that exist there.
And they're
interested in history.
The Catholic community in the
greater Washington area, this
is also their history,
white and black Catholics
beyond the University.
So they're interested.
Of course we've
seen the formation
of essentially the
descendant community out
of the genealogical
research and organization
by descendants themselves.
And that's another public
and audience that's
engaging in different ways.
So I think as those of
us who are scholars here,
you really have to
be aware that there
are all these
people out there who
could be really interested in
what you're doing if you just
find the right language,
the right stories,
and listen to them.
So it's really
exciting actually.
- And I'll just
say very briefly, I
think one of the
things that I suspect
a lot of people
worried about when
these conversations started
was that the study of,
and the publishing of the
history of these institutions'
relationship to slavery would
somehow tarnish our gates.
And in fact, actually what
happened is it opened them.
That real consequence
has been that we've
begun to see in fact,
surrounding communities
feel really empowered to make
claims upon the institutions
and to really be involved in the
decision making that happens.
Now that has all
sorts of consequences
to it because we can
talk about history,
but our present
isn't that great.
We're not necessarily
good neighbors now.
And so there are
consequences to that,
but actually I love
the fact that one
of the consequences of
what we've been doing,
of what all of these different
movements on campuses have done
is it's made people
feel like they have
a much greater stake in the
institutions themselves,
and certainly a
right to be heard
in institutions that are
supposed to be serving
in the public interest.
And they've now defined
themselves as that public.
And I think that's
a great consequence
and it's a great
opportunity for us now.
- Thank you very much.
So we're going to open up
now to questions and answers.
And here are the questions.
So from Agassiz--
we have not been
successful at telling the
stories we know are true.
The people who
arguably need most
to understand these
stories and don't yet,
are some of the most
resistant to listening.
How can we break through, not
just leading them to the water,
but making them drink, or put
it this way as it's written,
making drinking more attractive.
[LAUGHTER]
- Who would like to take that?
- It's your quote.
- Yeah, OK.
Well one the one thing is--
one strategy to get people
to think about something
they're not really
willing to think about
is just connect it
to where they are,
where they live, where they
study, where they teach.
So I think that's
something we've all
been finding as we
do this research
at our own universities.
When you tell students
that you would not
be sitting in this
Georgetown classroom
if it were not for the history
of slavery, It's more real.
It's less abstract.
It's closer to home.
It's not so remote.
And you might not convince them,
and they might still resist,
but they at least have to
confront the fact in a new way.
So that's part of it.
You're not going to
convince everyone,
but you might get more people
to listen a little more closely.
- OK, now here's actually
the most popular question,
or the most I guess,
highest number of people
have asked this question--
what will Harvard and
other universities
do-- now you can
answer for Harvard but,
what will other universities
do specifically to redress ways
that they have benefited from
their own institutional racism?
Would institutions take the
idea of reparations seriously?
- That they give reparations?
- Yes, In other words that these
universities have all in them,
obviously racist stories,
and even institutionally,
when we talked about the
medical school, for example,
and that kind of issue
that happened in the past,
so would these institutions
take the idea of reparations
seriously?
- Yeah.
I think that-- the
Brown report includes
a set of recommendations.
And part of, it
seemed to us, that it
would be rather incoherent for
us to do this investigation,
to disclose all of this and
say, well, glad the work's done.
There has to be some act
in the present that you--
some response to what you now
know about your institution's
history.
And so, in some
ways, that consumed
as much of our attention as
the historical research did
and trying to think through
what would be meaningful.
I think our guiding
principle was
that Brown was a university,
and that whatever remedies
we proposed should be
commensurate with Brown's
nature as a university.
Rhode Islanders made a
huge fortune, much of which
flowed into Brown through
the West Indian provisioning
trade, actually
providing salt cod which
became the staple diet of
enslaved people in Jamaica.
Well there's a lot
of heart disease
in Jamaica as a result of
the diet that people have.
So should Brown give everybody
in Jamaica a heart transplant?
No, because that's
not what we do.
So for us, we thought
really very carefully
that whatever actions
we took should
be in keeping with our
fundamental nature, which
is to produce knowledge,
to disseminate knowledge,
to deploy that knowledge
in ways that creates
a better, more just world.
And so our recommendations kind
of flowed from that premise,
so it included some comments
and recommendations related
to endowment
policy, gift policy.
It did not include, we
debated this, scholarships.
One of the things
that we've decided,
and this is true at Harvard as
well, Brown was a need blind,
need based institution, so
that everyone who was admitted
had the ability to receive
financial aid to make
it possible for them to
come, and that Brown didn't
have a policy, as Harvard
and others don't, of any kind
of scholarships that are
tagged to particular categories
of people, be that a football
player or whatever else
it might be.
And we actually decided
that that was right.
That that's where it should be.
But that Brown could act
much more aggressively
in diversifying its classes.
That brown could also
provide financial aid
for students from Africa
and the West Indies, who
are at that point were
not eligible for need
blind admission.
We also thought a great
deal about our relationship
with the surrounding community.
And so several of
the recommendations
were just in the spirit of
making the resources of Brown
available more broadly.
So we provided curricula
for local schools, students
who wish to teach in the
Providence public schools
get free scholarships
to come and do
master's degrees in
teaching at Brown.
Ruth Simmons devised
something which
I thought was really quite
creative, and I had thought
might be emulated, that
Brown raises funds now,
as part of its
endowment, and manages
funds that can be
designated as a trust fund
for the children of Providence.
And so Brown people
can make donations
and it will be to facilitate
educational programs
for the children of Providence.
And that those funds
will be managed
and that endowment
will be managed as part
of Brown's regular endowment.
So I thought that was a
really creative device.
At the end of the day,
apropos of the conversation
we heard this morning,
nothing you do in the present
even approaches the
significance and scale and scope
of the crime.
That doesn't mean we
can't do anything.
- Anybody else want
to tackle that one?
- I know there's something
of a debate about
whether or not what Georgetown
has proposed and done
constitutes reparations or not.
That sort of depends what
you think of as reparations,
whether you have a broad
idea of reparations
like gestures of reconciliation,
or a form of reparations
or not.
One of the most tangible
and discussed consequences
of the discussion at
Georgetown was the provision,
basically saying that the
descendants will receive
legacy status, something
like legacy status
for purposes of admission.
So they'll be treated the same
as the children of alumni.
And that gets towards a kind of
reparationist kind of policy.
But it's pretty modest at best.
And some of the
descendants themselves
have been saying, well
what about people who
don't want to go to Georgetown?
What about people who
can't get into Georgetown?
Doesn't Georgetown have some
kind of moral responsibility
to help subsidize and pay for
the education of those folks?
I'm so tempted to ask for a show
of hands, how many people think
that would be a good idea,
but I'm not going to do that.
- But it might be good, it
might be good just because--
can I just say that someone
else has asked very specifically
about what have the Jesuits
done for the descendants.
And then the second question
to that was, are they in need,
I guess the descendants.
What, if you do
something for somebody,
do you address
their specific needs
or do you address
something else?
So what has Georgetown
done, was the question,
so you can continue.
- All right.
How many people
in the room think
that Georgetown should
subsidize tuition
for descendants who attend
other schools than Georgetown?
Let me see you hands.
- At least.
- At lease.
At least, OK.
- Well the majority has it.
- Done.
[LAUGHTER]
- Call DC.
- They're going to call me.
This is one of the
reasons why I say
that the recommendations
of the working
group and the policies that
have been enacted to date
are really a beginning.
I think we've opened
up a conversation
where this sort of discussion
is now possible perhaps.
I don't know where
it's going to go.
I don't know if
Georgetown will ever--
or the Jesuit Order
will ever make
that additional commitment.
I just don't know.
I think it's basically
a matter of politics.
People fighting for it and
seeing what will happen.
There's a difference between--
today the Georgetown
University is
separate from the Jesuit
Order organizationally and all
of that, so there are sort of
separate questions about what
Georgetown is doing
as the university,
and what the Jesuit
Order is doing.
I'm not speaking for
either institution.
But I do think that the question
of Jesuit responsibility
is really important
and interesting one.
It's not just the
Jesuits, though.
Maybe next year we
could have a conference
called religion and
slavery, and look at all
of the religious institutions,
like the Jesuits,
who are deeply implicated
in the slave economies.
And of course, as
Craig has shown,
so many of these
universities began
as religious institutions.
So the question of
religion and slavery
is intimately tied
to the question
of universities and slavery.
But it's just another
area of American life
that is rooted in the
history of slavery in ways
that we do not--
most of us do not even
know the extent of.
- OK here's another question.
This morning Ta-Nehisi Coates--
Ta-Nehisi Coates warned
against self-congratulation.
How can we guard against that
danger and still do real work,
but not allow ourselves
to think we are better?
And I am assuming,
by allow ourselves
to think we are in the
sense that, well, we
have addressed this issue and
now we have finished our work.
Can you speak to that issue
of self-congratulation
or the fear of doing that.
- I think one of the concerns
for a lot of the people who
are involved in these
struggles and on campuses
is what happens?
What happens with their work?
And the universities that
have produced reports--
the universities,
and conferences,
if you use the report
or the conference
as the punctuation marks
of your relationship,
your engagement with an embrace
of your history with slavery,
then by definition
in fact, there's
going to be a large audience
of disappointed people.
And there's going to be a lot
of self-congratulatory behavior
because you have a kind
of spectacular moment
and then you move on.
And so I think one of the things
that we have to really think
about at all times
is how we start
to institutionalize
what we're learning
and what we're investigating
at our universities,
and put into practice real
policy and ways of thinking
about how we will
actually use this history
to transform ourselves.
And in the first question
that you had asked me,
which I kind of
didn't answer, which
was about the naming
practices on these campuses,
really in many ways I'm
not that interested in what
happens to most names of
buildings and structures
and things.
I think there are
egregious examples that
just need to be changed
because they're outrageous.
There are a lot
that are actually,
what we might refer
to as academics, who
have teachable moments,
things that we can really
use to talk about our history
and to get the public engaged
with that history.
But there's also--
I think one of the
things we can do
is we can actually start
to take an honest look
at our own traditions and
our own internal cultures,
in the way that we actually
use history and tradition,
we sort of weaponized
those terms
to shut down conversations
from students of color,
communities of color, and often
white women who make demands
upon our institutions.
Our traditions tend to be
extraordinarily unstable.
We change things all the time.
We're sitting in a
complex that has been
transformed by coeducation.
Coeducation at Dartmouth brought
a change to the Alma mater,
to the song.
Men of Dartmouth
doesn't work anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
- They changed the whole
curriculum in order
to keep the number of men, while
increasing the number of women.
You go to the quarter system.
We made radical changes
to the curriculum.
to our campuses.
Yale tried to buy Vassar.
As its way to
coeducation, it attempted
to just get Vassar
to move to New Haven
and solve its problems that way.
And when that didn't work it
created a 12 college consortium
so that they could share
students and actually
experiment in coeducation
in the late 1960s.
Williams did something that
today would seem outrageous.
In order to go coed, they got
rid of the entire fraternity
system.
We know for a fact that
a lot of our traditions
have been extraordinarily
unstable over time.
And one of the most unstable
things on our campuses
has been building names.
- Well, can I ask this because--
- Which only become sacred
when people complain.
- No, no, this is a
really good point,
and I have a question from
a Yale student who is glad
to live in Hopper College
rather than Calhoun College,
but and this is an important
question that's being asked
here, does re-naming just let
universities off the hook too
easily?
- Well, it depends
on what they do.
You have to actually
memorialize the renaming.
The renaming doesn't
erase history
because the name change
actually becomes part
of the history of the building.
And history is a
record of change.
History assumes change.
And so you're not
erasing history at all,
you're in the process
of creating history.
And part of our
obligation, if we're
going to be honest about these
conflicts and these moments,
is we have to historicize
the name change.
With Georgetown, it certainly
wasn't good enough just
to take the names of two
Jesuits who negotiated the 1838
sale off the buildings.
That doesn't do a
lot at all except
hide the embarrassment
of that one moment.
The real test of character
comes when one actually renames
the building and
then memorializes
the reason for the change.
The ground shift in the way
that you think about your past,
the way that you use
your past on campus,
and the way that you actually
deploy the past in presenting
yourself.
I think the big
challenge for us today
is not so much that our
students are making demands
or their communities
outside making demands,
the big challenge
is really what is
the obligation of 21st
century universities
with global influence,
whose reputations and status
depend upon maintaining--
depend upon maintaining
diverse communities
of students and scholars.
What is the public
presentation that we want.
And that's the conversation
that we need to start having.
And it's one that really
I think that's where
we need to start incorporating
history into our policymaking.
- You know, I just on
that I've become, partly
as a result of getting involved
in the enterprise at Brown,
increasingly less a historian
in the first sentence
of investigating history,
one, what actually happened,
and increasingly a historian
of memory or somebody
who is interested
in that other sense.
We use the term history of
the stories that people tell.
And there is a relationship
between those two things,
but it's not a very tidy one.
And I've become persuaded that
almost every time a human being
makes a political
claim in the present,
they are implicitly
or explicitly making
a claim about the
past, and vice versa.
And so that when we
alter the stories
that we tell about our past, as
a society or as institutions,
we alter the matrix of political
possibility in the present.
And we've seen, there was
a reference earlier today
to Gone With the Wind.
Here's a little
footnote for you,
everybody knows that Roots,
when it was broadcast,
was the most watched television
show in American history
at the time.
What most people don't know
was it was a, over two nights,
rebroadcast of Gone
With the Wind four years
before that it displaced.
And we've seen
the kind of damage
that the romancing of
slavery and the effacing
of the essential
violence and plundering,
to use this morning's word
of the Jim Crow regime,
the implications that had in
massive resistance in the South
and so forth.
So we've seen the ways in which
bad or incomplete or distorted
histories create political
impulses in our present
that are unnerving,
dangerous, hurtful, damaging.
And I think we're living through
such a moment now to be sure.
So part of the faith of this
is that if you alter the--
you transform what people
understand about their history,
you also create new political
possibilities in the present.
But it doesn't
happen automatically.
What it does is it just
changes the terrain
of political struggle.
But you still have
to do the work.
And if anybody thinks
you know that, OK we
changed the name
of John C Calhoun
or we published our report or
we apologized two weeks ago,
our work is done, then
they're just delusional.
The struggle never goes away.
- Can I say one thing about
this self-congratulations idea.
I think if you really appreciate
his history in the right way,
it teaches humility rather
than self-congratulations.
Has anybody here heard of
this musical, Hamilton?
[LAUGHTER]
- So George Washington sings--
- Tell us about it.
- --sings a song, he says--
the lyric is, history
has its eyes on you--
history has its eyes on you.
So I think one of
the lessons here
is we are now judging
and condemning
these institutions for their
participation in slavery 150
years ago, 150 years from now,
what will we be judged for?
What will history what will
historians 150 years from now
say about universities
complicity
in the production
of knowledge that
supports war, mass
incarceration, and poverty.
What will they say about that?
So that's the thing
that haunts me
as the core lesson
of this history.
And it is an antidote
to self-congratulations.
- And can I just--
- This is absolutely critical.
The great danger of these
kinds of enterprises
is that we can point our hands,
or point a finger accusingly
at somebody in our
past and in the process
congratulate ourselves on our
own superior moral wisdom.
And I just echo what Adam said.
For me, there's
this kind of moment
of reflection of
people are going
to ask the same question
of us in the future.
And part of what you want to
do through these exercises
is in investigating the
boundaries of moral imagination
of people in the past, that's
an invitation to investigate
the moral and
political boundaries
of your own imagination
in the present.
That's what these
things are for.
- And I was just
going to add, I think
they allow of ways to
create the constituencies
for different kinds of
conversations on campus.
So for instance, engaging
with the history of slavery
and the slave trade
doesn't actually
negate or block
our ability to talk
about Native American
history on our campuses
and the ways in
which that's actually
built into the landscape
of our campus--
the built environment
of our campuses.
That it doesn't
negate our ability
to talk about contemporary
problems of universities
and society.
Well, in other words,
we often in fact
use history, or other histories
and put them in competition,
so that we can pretend
we're not capable of a kind
of moral multitasking.
And we are.
- We are, yes.
Now this is an interesting
question for you, Professor
Rothman, and many
people don't know this,
I happen to know
this but, Healey--
President Healey was a person
of African descent and he --
and in fact there were two of
them, the brothers actually.
This person, Patrick
and, what was one's name?
James, I think.
James.
There's a few.
- Yes.
So he was the president
of Georgetown,
a person of African descent.
It's been a question, and
the person wants to know,
do people at Georgetown know
that part of their history,
or is that even identified?
In the Washington area, all
the people in Washington,
and I'm from Washington, that
story is told and retold.
And even during the day,
there's a big debate,
well was he just passing.
And then they'll
say, well no, he
wasn't passing because
in that period, what
was that late 19th--
- It was 18--
late 1870s and 1880s.
- Yeah, 1870s, yeah.
That he's speaking in
the black community.
And then so then so
they just cover it
and that's why he
lost his position.
But then there's some people
that have other stories.
So do they talk about Healey?
- At Georgetown?
- Yes.
- Incessantly.
[LAUGHTER]
- It's-- it's my birthday
today and that was a gift.
- Oh, happy birthday.
- Because I get to talk
about Patrick Healey,
one of the most fascinating
characters in Georgetown's
history.
So Patrick Healey
was born a slave.
His mother was an
enslaved woman in Georgia.
His father was a Irish
immigrant cotton planter.
Patrick Healey's parents
lived together as peers
and almost like a common law--
it would have been illegal
for them to be married,
but they lived together for
years in a kind of common law
marriage.
The father recognized the
paternity of his children.
He sent them to Northern
Catholic schools.
- There's even a daughter.
- There's a daughter.
So Patrick Healey
becomes a Jesuit
and becomes president
of Georgetown.
One of his brothers becomes
the Bishop of Maine.
A sister becomes the prioress
of a convent in Montreal.
And in the black
sheep of the family
goes out and becomes a Coast
Guard captain in Alaska.
[LAUGHTER]
- So it's a fascinating family.
And basically they're
very light skinned.
Patrick Healey essentially
passes for white.
Most people in Washington--
the Jesuits know his heritage,
his background, but
most other people don't.
And if they did,
he would never have
become president of Georgetown.
It wasn't until the
1950s that historians
began to unearth his ancestry.
And then in the
1960s, Georgetown
begins to celebrate Healey
as the first African-American
president of a major
white university,
even though nobody
knew it at the time.
So it's a very--
so now we're trying
to tell a bit more
of a complicated and
nuanced story about Healey.
But I think it's also
important to recognize
that as the story is
told about Healey being
the first African-American
president at Georgetown, what's
not usually told as
part of that story,
is the fact that
Georgetown did not
admit its first African-American
student until 1950.
So I think that juxtaposition
is an interesting one
to think about.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]